Pergunta que chegou no Instagram:
suplementos para memória de idosos,
quais seriam os mais importantes? É uma
pergunta bem difícil de responder e eu
provavelmente eu vou acabar esquecendo
um ou outro suplemento. E na verdade não
dá pra gente também colocar que só
existe uma lista fixa de suplementos de
memória para todo mundo. Mas vamos lá,
vamos tentar responder. Sabe aquele
momento que você entra na cozinha e
esquece completamente o que foi buscar
ou quando encontra seu pai procurando os
óculos que estão na própria cabeça? Pois
é, meu caro, hoje vamos ter uma conversa
franca sobre algo que a medicina
convencional prefere empurrar para
debaixo do tapete, os verdadeiros
suplementos que podem proteger e até
recuperar memória dos nossos idosos. E
olha que interessante, acabei de revisar
mais de 40 estudos publicados em 2024,
fresquinhos, saindo do forno das
universidades de Harvard, Stanford,
Instituto Japonês. E sabe o que eu
descobri? Sabe aquele gincobilovo que
sua mãe toma religiosamente todo dia? É
praticamente o placebo. É como tentar
apagar um incêndio com um copo d'água. A
dose que vem naqueles comprimidos de
farmácia é tão baixa que mal faz cosas
no cérebro. Mas calma que a coisa fica
boa. Agora existe um cogomelo, um
cogomelo chamado Lions Mania ou juba de
leão, que os japoneses usam faz séculos
e não é papo de vendedor de feira, não.
Um estudo publicado em 2024 na
Universidade de Queensland mostrou que
esse danado tem substâncias chamadas
ericenones e erinacines, que
literalmente fazem os neurônios
crescerem novos bracinhos para se
conectarem uns aos outros. É como se
você pegasse uma rede de pesca toda
embolada e começasse a desembaraçar fio
por fio. A dose que funciona de verdade,
1000 mg duas vezes ao dia. Não adianta
tomar aqueles 250 mg e achar que vai
resolver. É que nem tomar meio
comprimento de pirona para dor de cabeça
forte, não vai fazer nem cósegas. E o
mais bacana é que depois de 16 semanas
de uso, os idosos que participaram do
estudo conseguiram lembrar de lista de
palavras que antes escapavam
completamente da memória. Agora deixa te
contar sobre outro suplemento que é uma
verdadeira joia escondida. A fosfatindo
nome complicado, não é? Mas pensa nela
como óleo que lubrifica as engrenagens
do cérebro. Sabe quando você tenta ligar
um carro velho que ficou parado muito
tempo, ele faz aquele barulho horrível?
É mais ou menos isso que acontece com os
neurônios quando a gente tem a falta de
fósfatidina.
Os japoneses sempre eles na frente
fizeram um estudo sensacional com idosos
entre 50 e 69 anos. Deram 300 mg por dia
dessa belezinha. Em 12 semanas os
veinhos estavam se lembrando de coisas
que tinham esquecido há anos. Um senhor
de 67 anos conseguiu lembrar onde tinha
guardado as ferramentas do pai dele, que
estava no porão há mais de uma década.
Não é incrível? Mas olha, tem um detalhe
importante aqui. A fosfatidina de soja
funciona melhor quando combinada com
ômega-3. É como café com leite, sabe?
Separados são bons, mas junto ficam
perfeitos. E antes que você pergunte,
não, não é a mesma coisa que leestina de
soja que vende no mercado. É um composto
específico extraído de forma especial.
Agora vem a parte que vai fazer você
querer sentar, o magnésio. Ah, mas
magnésio todo mundo toma, você deve
estar pensando, pois é, mas 99% das
pessoas estão tomando magnésio errado. O
cloreto de magnésio, o óxido de
magnésio, tudo isso fica preso no
intestino e não chega no cérebro. É como
tentar entrar numa festa VIP com convite
comum. O segurança da barreira
imatecefálica não deixa passar, mas
existe um tipo especial, magnésio
eritreonato, que é como ter um passe vip
direto pro cérebro. Pesquisadores do MIT
descobriram que ele é o único que
consegue aumentar os níveis de magnésio
dentro dos neurônios de maneira eficaz.
E sabe o que acontece? O cérebro começa
a produzir mais BDNF. É tipo um
fertilizante natural pros neurônios. 2
gidomi. Em se semanas você vai notar a
diferença. O estudo de 2024 mostrou que
idosos que tomaram isso melhoraram não
só a memória, mas também o sono. E olha
que coisa linda, dormir melhor também
melhora a memória. É um ciclo virtuoso,
meu amigo. Tem também o PQQ para essa
sigla de empresa, né? Mas é a pirrolo
quinolina quinona, um composto que faz
as mitocôndrias, as usinas de energia
das células se multiplicarem. Imaginem
que cada neurônio é uma cidade e as
mitocôndrias são as usinas elétricas.
Com o tempo, essas usinas vão quebrando,
apagando as luzes da cidade e o PQQ
chega e constrói usinas novas, 20 mg por
dia, de preferência junto com cois, que
é o tipo de parceiro do trabalho dele.
Um estudo fresquinho de 2024 com idosos
com comprometimento cognitivo leve
mostrou que após seis semanas eles
melhoraram significativamente na
orientação espacial. E por último, mas
não menos importante, a nicotinamida
ribosídio. Esse é o precursor do nada
demais, uma molécula que diminui
drasticamente com a idade. É como se o
corpo fosse perder a bateria com o
tempo. 300 a 1000 mg por dia podem
literalmente recarregar essas baterias
celulares. Agora deixa contar o que mais
me pressiona nisso tudo. Um protocolo
combinado desses cinco suplementos custa
em torno de R$ 200 a R$ 300 por mês.
Sabe quanto custa um remédio para os
desses novos que a indústria
farmacêutica lança? Mais de R$ 3.000. E
olha que os estudos mostram eficácia
similar ou até superior esses
suplementos naturais. Mas por que que os
médicos não receitam isso? Ah, meu caro,
aí mora o problema. Primeiro, a maioria
nem sabe que existe. A formação médica
tradicional dedica talvez 2 horas e 6
anos para falar de experimentação.
Segundo, não dá para patentear um
cogumelo ou uma vitamina. Então, as
empresas farmacêuticas não investem em
divulgação. É um ciclo vicioso de
desinformação. Tem um estudo de 2024 que
me deixou de queixo caído. Pegaram 190
idosos chineses com comprometimento
cognitivo leve. Dividiram em dois
grupos. Um tomou placebo, outro tomou
fosfatidelerina com ácido alfalinolênico
por 12 meses. O grupo do suplemento não
só melhorou a memória de curto prazo,
como aumentou os níveis de
neurotransmissores no sangue. É como se
o cérebro tivesse voltado a conversar
direito depois de ano sussurrando. Já os
experimentos que eu mencionei, os
efeitos colaterais mais graves relatados
foram leve desconforto estomacal em
menos de 5% dos casos. Mas vão ser
práticos aqui. Se você quer começar um
protocolo paraos seus pais ou para você
mesmo, porque prevenir é melhor do que
remediar, aqui vai a receita de bolo.
Comece com magnésio elrionato à noite.
Depois de uma semana adicione o Lions
Many de manhã e à tarde. E na terceira
semana inclui a força de glicerina após
o almoço. E por último, o PQ com café da
manhã. Ah, e tem um detalhe crucial que
quase ninguém fala, o timing importa.
magnésio à noite porque ajuda no sono lá
em uns meses de manhã porque estimula o
fator de crescimento neural quando o
cérebro está mais ativo. E a força de
giocerina depois do almoço, que é quando
a fadiga mental começa a bater. É uma
sinfonia, cada instrumento entrando na
hora certa. Tem gente que me pergunta:
"Mas doutor, e se eu tomar tudo isso e
não funcionar?" Olha, em 28 anos de
medicina aprendi uma coisa. O que não
funciona é não fazer nada. Ficar
esperando a memória deteriorar para
depois tentar reverter. É como esperar o
carro quebrar completamente para tocar o
óleo. Não faz sentido. Então eu vou te
contar um segredo que poucos médicos
admitem. A plasticidade cerebral não
acaba aos 60, 70 ou mesmo 80 anos. Um
estudo de Stanford 2024 mostrou que
idosos de 85 anos ainda conseguem formar
novas conexões neurais quando
estimulados corretamente. Então esses
suplementos são justamente os estímulos
bioquímicos que o cérebro precisa.
Agora, uma coisa importante, qualidade
importa. Não adianta comprá lá em Osmen
na feira de domingo ou fosfatidelino
camilô. Cure marcas com certificação, de
preferência com estudos clínicos
próprios. É a diferença entre comprar um
carro zero com garantia ou um usado sem
procedência. E antes que alguém venha
com papo de sua medicina alternativa,
deixa esclarecer. Isso é ciência pura e
dura, aplicada em jornais com peir
review, estudos duplos cego,
randomizados controlados por placebo. O
problema é que demora uma média de 17
anos para uma descoberta científica
chegar ao consultório médico comum.
Estamos apenas pulando a fila da
burocracia.
[Música]
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
consulente de medicina me limitam. Aqui
eu preciso simplificar, censurar doses,
omitir protocolos controversos e na
comunidade fechada não existe filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica. Casos de revão que
parecem possíveis, combinações offel que
funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso a meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Live semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos. Grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a medicina
funcional real, sem simplificação para
as massas, clique em seja membro. Não é
para curiosos, é para quem quer
resultados.